First, I'd like to thank you
for raising the most beautiful woman
I have ever seen.
And for allowing me to marry her.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you, Kola.
-Thank you.
Thank you for standing by me
all these years.
I know everything.
When are you going to get that?
Soon, you'll be king.
Yes.
Hey, the man of the hour!
I don't think I can do this thing.
-Do not embarrass me this day.
-I'm so sorry, Mommy.
You're ready to get married
to a man who does this to you?
He beats me.
So you're telling me you're willing
to let go of everything
because of one slap?
It can't be that bad.
You still want me
to do this at the wedding?
Yeah.
If anything happens to me,
look to our brother.
What I do know
is that he was a very violent man.
-And you know what they say.
-What in God's name is going on?
If you live by the sword…
I don't know. He just vanished.
I can't find him anywhere.
I need you to find
the people who did this…
and make them suffer.
Help me!
Sarah, we're no longer good girls, okay?
We're fugitives now.